on voulait vous montrer quelque chose et
tout le monde en parle actuellement
c'est vrai que ça fait un buzz diouf là
depuis quelques heures
c'est là une de charlie hebdo sur la
coupe du monde féminine choqué pas
choqué c'est parti on y va choquer pas
chaud on le sait charlie hebdo est un
journal satirique qui a fait sa gloire
grâce à la provocation sans limite et
liberté de ton devenu sa marque de
fabrique
c'est donc sans grande surprise que les
dessinateurs du journal ont décidé dans
leur prochain numéro de s'attaquer aux
sujets du moment la coupe du monde
féminine de football en pleine mutation
de la société est alors que le combat
pour la parité fait rage les
journalistes de charlie hebdo ont décidé
de jeter un pavé dans la mare en
choisissant une une qui ne manquera pas
de faire réagir
on va en bouffer pendant un mois alors
choqué ou pas choqué par cette une de
charlie hebdo de charlie qui fait
énormément parler
voilà donc franchement enlevé on le voit
là on l'avait un peu ne s'est pas
choquer valérie benaïm pas choquer alors
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi je
trouve que c'est une absolument
dégueulasse
voilà je la trouve pas drôle je la
trouve raté je la trouve nulle mauvaise
tout ce que vous voulez sauf que c'est
charlie hebdo il faut arrêter et à
géométrie variable a réussi on dit
qu'ils ont le droit de tout faire sont
là mais c'est quand michel
c'est sidérant c'est le fait le fait
qu'il vient d'un total hors prime avait
pas ne leur permet pas d'être nulle
maintenant pour les la faim jusqu'à la
fin des siècles elle n'est pas drôle il
n'y a pas de recouvrement le message y'a
rien au fond ils peuvent pas tout faire
parce qu'il ya eu un drame
franchement là il faut il faut sans trop
franchement la ccl l'édicule benjamin
castaldi a c'est pas drôle
alors on en a parlé hier sur d'autres
sujets où on essaie de faire avancer les
choses c'est une pour moi les
rétrogrades
effectivement c'est une illusion ou foot
féminin extérieur où ça nullissime
et ça me choque pas moi alors on va on
va parler de la sphère rigolo jérôme
rothen dans un instant on des
proportions incroyables et c'est vrai
qu'il ya plein de gens qui veulent
analogie j'ai vu sur twitter il ya plein
de gens qui ont suspendu ou rigolos et
rayonne sur rmc et là je vont faire les
bien pensants exactement 10 voilà alors
si c'est ce qu'il est actuellement barré
ce qu'ils disent actuellement il en
allait bien voilà mais moi je vous dis
ce qui se passe sur twitter actuellement
je suis ok ils disent qu'ils vous disent
qu'il se passe actuellement sur twitter
il ya plein de gens qui disaient ce qu'
ils vont réagir
voilà sur sept une vous êtes ce que vous
êtes choqué au pape une agence havas
il choqué par rapport à l'image me
connaissant charlie hebdo ils sont
toujours dans cette bêta dire quoi ça le
message c'est mettre des gens à dos je
suis pas charlie j'ai jamais été même
après les attentats c'est frais des
attentats c'était très grave ce qui
s'est passé pour eux et j'en suis
évidemment très déçu
pas très désolée surtout mais encore une
fois je trouvais car une était très
dangereuse s'est jamais drôle leur une
et parfois c'est dangereux on l'a vu que
les attentats sur vous servez pas drôle
là c'est pas drôle mais cac est sûr ce
n'était pas drôle très drôle et ce faux
côté de sous-entendus où les
contestataires on peut tout se permettre
bah non c'est juste pas drôle si nul
mathieu pouvait pas là là là où pouvais
pas dire non plus parce que c'est
dangereux qui a des attentats ne sais
pas ce que j'ai dit ce que j'ai
seulement dit c'est la première fois que
j'ai fait des caricatures on aime ou on
n'aime pas il ya eu ce drame derrière et
ensuite ils ont recommencé ensuite oui
mais bon oui mais si la liberté la
liberté comme c'est dangereux c'est dans
le nord ça peut créer des choses
dangereuses en argent nous enfants
malades là je suis avec vous géraldine
maillet alors pas du tout choquée je
pense que d'abord en fête le
bicentenaire de gustave courbet qui
avait fait voilà du monde et qui fait
allusion aux origines du mois cette auto
6 6 est cédée par le jeu très important
que ça il ya deux cents ans plus tard
courbet avait fait un grand choc
c'est tout le monde était en colère tout
le monde voulait brûler gustave courbet
brûlé le tableau moi tu personnel je
trouve que c'est pas du tout choquant
parce que je trouve que le foot au
contraire aujourd'hui féminin cartonne
vous savez que j'ai fait un documentaire
sur les footballeuses je les aime ces
d'héroïne et je pense qu'il faut pas
prendre des pincettes il faut pas
prendre des gants prévu pour moi non
mais pour moi le sexe et triomphant le
sexe de cette affiche là et triomphant
pour moi le ya une sorte de
vibromasseurs et ml ce dessein derrière
comme les gens doivent alors merci mes
géraldine lui nous chargerons fond c'est
quoi le message de ses blessures
mais pour moi c'est la femme triomphante
c'est la femme qui ça y'est s'impose
dans le foot c'est la femme qui est
traitée à ça le sera en fête
non ça c'est un peu corrosif c'est un
peu c'est un peu virulent mais moi ça ne
me gêne pas je sais alors là je suis
bien là moi aussi à l'étude
vous aller un peu loin isabelle
effectivement à l'origine du monde de
courbet sera produit en même temps moi
je devine des galas focus on the cabin
au tableau de courbet a failli on va en
bouffer pendant un match oui mais c'est
toujours dégueulasse bon on accepte sans
reno et on dit c'est dégueulasse mords
moi je dépêche charline 2100 dans la
droite ligne de leur rugby qui fait une
escapade eidos et ça va vous faire alors
alors là dix exemplaires les foules il a
vaincu pas y toucher des millions pour
ça alors il vous plaît je christine
kelly choquée moi je pense qu'on peut
parfois aimé et parfois ne pas aimer je
pense qu'on peut être à géométrie
variable fait la suisse et non mais
laissez moi terminer on peut être
féministe sans aimer tout ce que font
les femmes
on peut être vegan sans aimer tout ce
qu'en font les vegan on peut être
homosexuel sans aimer tout ce que font
les homosexuels on peut être de droite
sans aimer tout ce qu'on fait du pardon
et on peut être aussi quand peut être je
suis charlie en 2015 sans aimer toutes
les une de charlie a fêté ses cinq ans
avec je ne l'aiment pas d'accord et
pourquoi mais je n'aime pas parce que je
trouve que non seulement l'image le sexe
je n'ai pas envie d'expliquer cette
faute à ma fille de 5 ans deuxièmement
le sous titre je n'ai pas envie je
n'aime pas le sous titre on va en
bouffer pendant un mois pour moi c'est
péjoratif pardon je parle pour moi je
trouve que c'est péjoratif jeu mais
d'autres une mais celle-ci ne me plaît
pas du tout et puis dernier point au csa
par exemple on voit cette histoire de
rmc avec les deux chroniqueurs qu'on met
à pied parce qu'il ya un régulateur pour
les pour la les médias la radio et la
télé pourquoi il n'ya pas d'un
régulateur dans la presse écrite à la
presse écrite
l'état donne 300 millions d'euros par an
et au à la radio à la télévision
y'a pas le régulateur émission satirique
oui mais on a envie aussi que charlie
hebdo et que tous les journaux
satiriques puisse faire ce qu'ils
veulent moi je vous dit dans la presse
ou dans la télévision
il fonde alors la radio dans la
télévision ils font plus de mal qui me
font du bien pas quand ça blesse à la
télé ça alors du rabin
cette coupe du monde de football féminin
les petites filles pour avoir les mêmes
rêves que les petits garçons devenir
footballeur professionnel
perdre son permis au volant de sa
ferrari et se taper des [ __ ] c'est pas
de moi c'était de blanche gardin c'est
très important d'écrire de pouvoir
écrire ça on n'aura rien à voir si la
reine abla traiter les femmes
footballeuses comme des âmes footballeur
ça n'a rien à voir si jean-michel
voulait rebondir
non mais je comprends parce que moi
c'est une complètement sexistes on voit
pas en quoi c'est est-ce des propos qui
servent la cause des femmes se c'est une
là on va en bouffer ces gens là ils ont
merde moi je sais pas c'est important je
suis pourtant prêt à rire et umeda c'est
ce que voulait la vie de kelly et de doc
gynéco qu'on n'a pas entendu annoncé
bons américains comme gynéco la photo la
photo un dessin la photo et le texte est
indécent c'est quelque chose mais c'est
indécent chose mais est important c'est
ce que ça inspire en réali alors ça
inspire quoi ah bien ça moi ça va ce
pire des choses
à quoi bon c'est bon c'est tout ce
qu'ils voulaient dire quoi oui oui ne
fait pas attention aux textes fait là je
croyais ne fait pas attention à moi
demain on avait étudié de ce texte et
faites attention est ce que ça vous
inspire
est ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas par
là un peu la couv on peut la voir s'il
vous plaît oui ok ça vous inspire
alors je vous dis en tout cas sur
twitter les gens sont choqués honte à
vous charlie hebdo pour sept couvertures
insultantes et dégradantes
ils sont pas censés être drôle là c'est
loupé c'est vulgaire et ses tonnages du
charlie hebdo purs et durs comme on les
aime je sens poindre la polémique on va
en bouffer des jours et des jours
puisqu'un là qui ne sont pas choqués
également et c'est vrai que ce football
féminin en ce moment il ya eu plein de
dérapage sur le foot féminin
on a eu également alain finkielkraut qui
s'était exprimé sur le plateau de ces
news la semaine dernière et regarder ça
a été beaucoup parlent également non ma
fille tu le crois je vais parler de
votre passion vous me faites peur là on
allait avoir je pense celle ci donc fait
pour le football
et oui mais j'ai décidé que j'avais tant
elle est rudement la télévision de
football féminin ben alors
j'aime pas le comment ça pour quoi
quelle différence vous n'êtes pas le
dernière ça aussi mais là après on va
faire le rugby arrêté l'égalité
d'égalité bien sûr l'égalité mais un peu
de différence c'est pas c'est pas comme
ça que j'ai envie de voir des gens
formidables mais veston mieux parler je
souhaite la victoire de l'équipe de
france et ce sera très bien qu'elle
gagne son premier match entre la corée
du sud mais les jeux ne seraient pas
scotché devant ma télévision pour voir
un match de football féminin
voilà beaucoup fait parler paix sur les
une de charlie hebdo c'est pas la
première usine qui fait polémique qui
avait eu bien sûr la une sur johnny en
novembre deux mois après vous johnny
laisse tomber le rock et se met à
l'électro voilà ça c'est marrant attend
que ça m'arrive des gens qui répondent
oui mais il était malade
la balade en mai 2010 est qu'ils avaient
fait leur une sur le couple macron en
titrant il va faire des miracles
regardez non ça c'est drôle ça oui bah
ça peut être drôle ça peut plaire je me
sens fin de l'histoire
alors c'est pas joli enzo avait fait sa
police avait fait polémique aussi sur sa
une de stromae en mars 2016 et d'effets
allusion aux attentats de bruxelles est
la chanson papa août et de ce travail
voilà voilà voilà pour ça aussi voilà
c'est et puis voilà j'en vois et chaque
fois que c'est extrêmement bien dessiné
j'ai fait la répression de votre salon
est responsable comme un ovale contre
voudrait seconds rôles c'est pas drôle
comme ça blesse la sablaise avions une
personne et qui regardent les surtout
les soirées qui est en train de leur
dire vous êtes des cons c'est eux que ça
blesse quand ça blesse tout autant c'est
pas drôle c'est juste savoir moi je veux
dire moi le seul truc c'est vraiment
accroché et on a pu les charlie pourra
pas se mentir mais moi je dis la vérité
un charlie ne me fait pas rire du tout
malentendu airtran et demandent jamais
fait rien je trouve que l'on aime avant
tout c'est un humour de gens de plus de
90 puis choix voilà où 100 pigeons ou
les mecs peut-être qu'ils sont avant
garde
ah ouais ben alors pas d'âge mais hyper
parisianiste dans la toile